let's go to I don't know let's try the
four one nine area code call her from
four one nine who's this David yes hi my
name is Adam a huge fan is your sorry
what did I say your name was
Oh bad all right go ahead okay I had a
question in terms recently in a Twitter
you know Charlie Kurt yes I do
yeah he like threw out his back and had
some blood clot issue and then he was
taken to the hospital but then his
friend Kyle de shava think blamed the
whole thing like the lack of hospital
beds on the California's stands I guess
on California's health care system so so
the people are like making you know
jothika living like Kappa lives every
single day so what's your take on that
so I'm not at all aware of this I met
Kyle Kashif he came up and introduced
himself to me at politican in October in
Los Angeles and I mean he's you know he
was a perfectly nice kid to me although
I'm aware that his political views are
pretty pretty outrageous I don't know
you know having not seen the tweets at
all it's very hard for me to really
comment but the truth is that whatever
particular gripe you have with the
California health care system it's all
part of the broader for-profit health
care system that exists like any public
options any public hospitals any
subsidized subsidization of the system
it all exists within the disastrous
bigger picture for-profit health care
system that we have so I think it's
disingenuous and also totally
misdirected to say that anything good in
the system is because it's a for-profit
system and anything bad is because of
the elements in it that try to provide
services to everybody that's just
nonsense okay I have a quick question
also if you have time yeah okay so
there's also another thing I saw on to
whatever it was like remember that whole
what Craig University had videos of the
Cole Christian Baker thing where if you
yeah find another Baker yeah thing or
then also recently
University tried putting their ads on
Spotify and then Spotify banned their
ads and so now they're trying to put a
lawsuit on Spotify and claiming that
they're biased against conservative yeah
I saw that I'm actually in a
back-and-forth with Prager you the
Twitter account has been following me
for a long time and I got into a
back-and-forth with them about this and
I pointed out that there's a hypocrisy
here and they said no it's not a it's
not hypocrisy because this isn't about
they try to draw a distinction somehow
and it was so dumb that I don't even
remember it but then people piled on and
said no no you guys really are
hypocrites here right doesn't make any
sense of when it comes to their when it
comes to their apologies and beliefs if
that's being ignored that you know it's
because free speech is being censored
you know I'm remembering I think their
argument was we are not looking for the
government to fix this we just want to
tell people Spotify is doing this so
that people will stop using it and it's
like no you're pretty damn litigious
they've previously sued YouTube and
Google and like they're doing the exact
same thing it's pathetic yeah alright
thanks for the call yeah great to hear
from you